this is the era of the single the roots
made their mark based on a family
structure on collaborating my manager
now Richard Nichols are you trying to
Rack our brain trying to figure out this
Rubik's Cube of a mystery on the how to
survive in this industry we discovered
like Oh every success story and music is
based on being compared to a group with
someone else you think of the jiggy
rapaera you think jay-z you think little
Kim
big foxy you think of the Woodstock
generation I think Crosby Stills Nash
young it's like a family stone now and
even what Motown you say oh I love
Stevie one different know there's Stevie
the Four Tops Marvin Gaye so when we
were making our four thousand Things
Fall Apart we told our label look this
is gonna be another wasted budget if you
guys don't start from the ground floor
you're gonna have to sign like-minded
artists like the roots and we're all
gonna have to come out at the same time
that's how the soul the soul Quarian era
started with common Erica D'Angelo ttip
solo stuff slum village allow there is
like a group of us were compared
together it was like a brief great
moment at a time I mean right now yeah
it is the singles era like people don't
think in terms of
or community or projects just single